good morning John there is too much
going on in my life right now
I'm going on tour so I'm trying to learn
all of my songs well instead of the way
that I normally know them handle my desk
I'm gonna stop gesturing so much it's
dangerous something else as long as my
fingers hurt but that's not all that's
going on also I have this song in my
head all I want for Christmas is good
mani mani there are so many wonderful
songs I can have in my head right now
you would not believe your eyes
ten million fireflies or more
appropriately I got nothing
can't see me baby look to my hace I'm
acting crazy nothing that's really what
we should all be listening to because
the chartjackers project has culminated
the internet wrote a song and then the
internet gave that song to a charity and
now whatever money that song makes goes
to that charity which is why I'm going
to ask you to visit the link in the
sidebar and go and buy I've got nothing
by charge ackers if you were unfamiliar
with the product there's a video
explaining it in the sidebar as well but
basically for youtubers got together and
helped the internet write a song and
they're trying to jack the charts by
selling the song for charity so far the
song is in the top 100 of America's
iTunes charts and the top 25 of the UK's
iTunes charts but in order to get in the
top 10 they need a lot more like more
than they had so far just to get in the
top 10 it becomes a very sort of
clustering mass down at the bottom of
the scale I mean and it's just $1 and
you've got iTunes probably so click the
link also occasionally amazing things
happen at the Ning fairly regularly
really and we don't always talk about it
but sometimes we just have to mention
when there's a person who is making
Ducky's out of people and the Ducky's
Ning master will make a rubber duck out
of anyone who wins the weekly ducky
contest and in sad news my name is Chris
yeah who was a really great young
blogger and has a collab project with
one of my favorite dudes on YouTube bill
TV makin bill makin TV I think it's bill
making tea I don't know was in a serious
car accident last week and I just sort
of want everyone to sort of try and
think about him and wish him all the
best in his recovery it always hurts
when a member of you
community isn't doing well so let's all
try and be there for him I put a link to
his channel in his sidebar and you can
leave a comment on his channel and you
can subscribe to him that way when he
comes back they'll have all these new
people who want to see his great videos
so while I've been trying to play and
learn all my songs I've also been making
a little bit of a setlist here I'm not
gonna show you what's on it yet but I
want to know people what do you want me
to play in my shows I want to please you
how does my job is to please you so
basically at the events I want to play
songs I want to talk I want to answer
questions if anyone has any questions
I'm looking to play whatever you want me
to play so please in the comments you
can tell me what you want me to talk
about but you can also tell me what
songs you want me to sing and that way I
can try and please the most number of
people because I can't play all my songs
sorry John that is all I wish you could
come with me on my tour cannot I'm gonna
put up that graphic again now because I
have new information about Phoenix and
Portland sorry Seattle still working on
it it'll go up as soon as I know so
please click on your place and learn
where I'm going to be and what I'm going
to do where you are John you'll see me
tomorrow
you